los investigadores rusos no dudan de que
el crimen fue cuidadosamente planificado
la bomba que mató al área dubina estaba
puesta debajo del coche en el lado del
conductor el canal de televisión shark
crat muy conservador donde trabajaba
como periodista y editorialista le
rindió homenaje nuestra amiga aliada y
afín daria turina fue asesinada de forma
cobarde y vil en un intento de hacernos
sufrir al máximo a nosotros pueblo ruso
patriotas e imperialistas a pesar de su
juventud tarea divina era una auténtica
guerrera rusa un recuerdo eterno y
luminoso según el medio de comunicación
estatal estás divina regresaba a la
capital rusa tras asistir a un festival
con su padre alexander during él era el
objetivo según sus familiares pero
decidió cambiar de coche en último
momento el ideólogo ultranacionalista
aboga desde hace tiempo por la
unificación de los territorios de habla
rusa popularizó conceptos como 1 hora
silla o nueva rusia para justificar la
anexión de crimea en 2014
él y su hija fueron firmes partidarios
de la guerra en ucrania y estaban en la
lista de sancionados de eeuu el líder de
la región separatista de donets acusó a
kiev de orquestar la explosión un
escenario improbable para este analista
no creo que ucrania tenga nada que ganar
no pueden permitirse el lujo de ser
retratados como terroristas creo que
nuestro estilo no es porque sean los
buenos ni nada por el estilo simplemente
no sirve para sus propósitos partes es
las autoridades ucranianas niegan
cualquier implicación un asesor del
presidente de lens kit dijo que el
ataque podría haber sido llevado a cabo
por facciones políticas rusas